this vlog is in memory of Susan Solomon
atmospheric chemist and discoverer of
the CFC mechanism of ozone destruction
in the southern hemisphere which isn't
dead
I just need to remind myself who she is
if you don't understand that reference
then make sure you go back and watch my
aju vlogs and when I was in America
presenting my research at a conference
in San Francisco but welcome back to the
vlogs it's been a while sorry I kind of
been busy a crazy amount of stuff that's
been happening in my life across
basically every aspect of it so let's
get going the biggest piece of news is
that I have been incredibly lucky to be
selected by the foundation to decrease
worldsuck which is a foundation that's
been set up by the vlogbrothers Hank and
John Green and they've given me
incredibly generous financial support to
buy equipment for this channel so I have
a new camera the I'm not using this to
film it because when it's shipped they
didn't include a charger thank thanks
for that but I've got a whole bunch of
new equipment this new camera this
microphone a green screen that I
definitely didn't spend seven minutes
trying to fall back up after I popped it
up for the first time the new lens that
you're watching me through and a whole
bunch of other equipment and I couldn't
honestly say I never ever thought that I
would be receiving funding from the
vlogbrothers although they'd even watch
one of my videos so you know this is
only possible because the people are
watching these videos so thank you so
much now I've got to put this stuff to
good use with that in mind there's going
to be a video coming out I think this
week on what's gonna be coming out on
this channel and where I talk about my
plans for the channel and what I think
Simon Oxford is basically gonna be all
about but also I'm really excited to say
that I am making a short film there's a
society here at Exeter called X TV and
I'm working with a bunch of really
talented people to make a short film
between me my experience of my new
flashing camera I'm going to be the
director of photography for this film
and that'd be coming out sometime in the
next couple of weeks when I know more
about that I'll let you know
the other big thing that's been
happening is singing related so many of
you know I sing in my University's
Chapel Choir I'm a choral
here extra and we are making a CD it's
got an amazing repertoire on it ranging
from luck of the I think 15th century to
the 20th century going from Allegra's
Miserere to stuff from the king singers
and in the middle of that there's a
piece book called the turtles earth by
Ralph Vaughan Williams and in it there's
a whacking great leaf baritone solo it
beginning in at the end and um I'm doing
that so I'm gonna be a CD recorded
soloist this is crazy and when that
becomes available I will let you guys
know that's gonna happen
that's really really excited and also
talking about Chapel Choir news we are
going to be going on tour this year to
Italy now some of you will have seen the
videos I did last year where we went to
Germany and went to stick up Robyn's
Bergen Friedreich's - go and watch the
vlogs if you haven't ready because I'm
really proud of them I think they're
some of my best videos now we are
funding ourselves going to Florence this
year last year we were very lucky to
have support chaplaincy this year we
don't have that money so we are raising
it ourselves there is a donation link
down there in my pants
and if you would like to support us even
if it's just a few pounds dollars yen
whatever will be incredibly appreciated
and if you leave a donation message
saying that you came here from this
video that Simon sent you
I'll make sure that we record something
in those vlogs from Florence to say
thank you because you know it's only
through those kind of donations that we
can go so phd watch time
so since San Francisco I've been working
extensively on the theory and then if
you're actually able to see this but
I've been filling out pages of my
notebook with endless endless equations
because I realized that the work that I
was doing in preparation for San
Francisco but didn't quite get finished
in time was actually wrong and I could
prove it in three lines a bit sad but
I'm also kind of pleased that I can I've
got to the stage where I can just look
at and go oh no you can just miss that
with you know it's also an opportunity
to start again
which I've done repeatedly in this book
and effectively what I'm doing is I'm
working with the full equations that
govern how air moves over the northern
hemisphere
and I'm simplifying them down and saying
how simple can they be and you still get
a meaningful answer how can you be that
explains the phenomenon were looking at
and the simplest case you can prove
pretty easily that you get nothing
you can't show anything with those
equations in terms of the phenomenon
we're looking at and what I'm Carolee
looking at is the next stage up in
complexity and just today in fact and in
here I've got to a partial differential
equation in two variables it's any
second-order actually that I'm going to
be solving and hopefully proving that
it's either zero or something that's
interestingly not zero and then the next
stage is simulating that and the other
big bit of PhD news I'm going to be
presenting it in Vienna I'm going to the
EGU which is the European geosciences
Union and presenting my work hopefully
in a talk and at the same time I'm gonna
be on a panel I'm going to be on a panel
talking about social media in academia
talking about my vlogging talking about
tweeting about science and generally
yeah answering questions from other
scientists about how to engage the
public and wouldn't be possible if not
for you guys and you're watching me and
engaging with me so thank you so much
this all my life is really quite awesome
at the moment while I say it's awesome
I've got to solve this equation and I've
got about 76 days I think from now to
get that written up and then I've also
got a thesis chapter doing in like a
month which yeah that the deadlines are
coming thick and fast at the moment but
I get to do all some science and play
with equations that I kind of fell in
love with him either
every day so I can't complain
time for what Simon is reading I want to
kind of do this as a regular second
where I talk about the books I've been
reading because you guys really like the
video made talking about my favorite
books so recently I read the Waterloo
book but I started talking about in that
video I can attest now I demolished it
in the flight over to San Francisco is
probably the best historical account
I've ever read it was absolutely
gripping if you like historical
particularly military history it's
essential read it I'm halfway through
consider fleebus it's actually quite
hard going as somebody commented on the
video it takes you a while to visualize
what in banks is talking about but yeah
it's just I've never known a book with
this kind of imagination it's really
good and it's different sci-fi it's what
I've read before and then in the supreme
display of willpower I caved in both two
new books I bought what if by Randall
Munroe this is actually a book based on
the blog you might know you probably
know him from xkcd like the most famous
geeky web comic there is he also did
another book what if where he answers
serious scientific no silly scientific
questions with serious answers and I can
honestly say if you are thinking of
applying to Oxbridge for science subject
read this book and I also got this book
called infinitesimal which is about the
development of calculus and how it was
kind of piratical I haven't started this
yet but I've been thinking about making
a video about this for a little while so
if in a couple of months a video pops
out you can probably in this book let me
know in the comments by the way if
you're reading anything that is
particularly gripping you at the moment
lastly I want you guys to interact with
me a bit on this one there's two things
that I want you to do one I kind of
would like to be able to upload a video
and put a hash tag on it I want to mean
something to to us not just me but to us
as a as this two-way interaction up
until now we've had team nipples which
came from high revision videos and I'd
rather not use that one if I'm honest we
also have team sweet popcorn which is
because it's the true light it's you
know anybody who likes popcorn or movies
it likes sweet popcorn and then most
recently on Twitter I ran a poll talking
about whether people prefer a starter
main course or a main course and pudding
and the obvious answer that is you have
a main course and pudding so maybe team
pudding
well maybe none of these will
and you know you have that a suggestion
so put down the comment to your
suggestions for what hashtag if I was to
use one we should use and then lastly
I'm gonna be doing a Q&A video to
celebrate passing 25,000 subscribers so
if you have any questions that are not
Oxbridge access related they can be
silly or serious whatever you want put
them in the comments and I will record
that sometime next week know one more
thing
Oscar predictions on the massive film
geek if you have any predictions about
who's gonna win the Academy Awards this
year it's particularly the
cinematography category comment down
below thank you for watching I really
hope that you liked the new kind of
production values with Mike and the
camera and making this a bit more of
like almost like a show I guess like
more with segments and comment below
with all the stuff I talked about and if
you're feeling generous please do
support the chapel choir tour that's the
one in my pants if you enjoyed this
please like it and I'll see you guys
sometime later this week because I'm
uploading a lot videos at the moment bye
so whilst we've been on those very long
look here we've been able to go past a
lot of different sections and it's worth
pointing out the the diversity of
science here is incredible so we just
went past climate change solutions
forest ecology
my youtube described the concert